as with every james gunn movie observant
fans will notice plenty of extra goodies
and easter eggs hiding in plain sight
and his latest superhero adventure is no
exception here are several of the more
subtle references and easter eggs that
you missed in the suicide squad
moments before the battle on yotenheim
task force x briefs the thinker on the
myriad ways he needs to behave himself
lest they dispatch him with extreme
prejudice during this rooftop scene
harley quinn repeatedly interjects with
jokey cautions about things like
covering his mouth whenever he coughs
the easter egg however is buried in one
of these lines if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you don't vanity plates can often be
annoying so the lion gets a laugh
whether you read something deeper into
it or not but harley's hatred of vehicle
signage is actually a reference to her
ex-boyfriend
none other than the joker it's also one
of the only times in the suicide squad
where they acknowledge the existence of
the earlier film
in the previous outing for the titular
team the joker was infamously played by
jared leto much like everything else
with the first movie the initial
response to his look was massive
promising internet buzz
but the final product has subsequently
been deemed a disappointment
symbolic of the letto joker's on the
nose tendencies that made him hard to
swallow was his vehicle
an adapted infiniti g35 dubbed the vader
a vehicle also featured vanity plates
that read hahaha
harley has since moved on in the
relationship department but clearly
she still has some things that annoy her
when it comes to her ex puddin
when the team assembles in a charming
local corto maltese watering hole for a
few drinks the club contains several
notable faces
one of the dancers is none other than
palm clement tf the distinctive looking
canadian-born french actor and model who
played mantis in 2017's guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 as well as avengers
infinity war and adventures end game she
doesn't have any lines this time around
but sharp by james gunn fans know that
he has a tight fun-loving group of
friends and collaborators
it's fun to see her offering support for
the filmmaker you can also spot the
legendary lloyd kaufman he's the
mastermind behind the troma
entertainment indie film factory and
he's given rise to multiple film talents
including gun
who in 1995 got to start riding tromeo
and juliet
it was that trauma that gunn learned how
to write and produce films scout
locations work with actors and make and
distribute ads for the finished product
gun also worked on such other trauma
productions as 1999's terror firmer
kaufman can be spotted on the dance
floor clinging to a young woman while
dancing alongside peacemaker to be a fly
on the wall for whatever conversation
took place between those two
gun also pays tribute to his former
mentor kaufman with a blink and you'll
miss it clip from troma's most famous
film
the 1984 cult classic the toxic avenger
next time you watch the suicide squad
see if you can spot it
a pair of end credit scenes bring back
two members of the suicide squad
these two characters could not be any
more different never met in the film and
would seem to have very different
futures in the dc extended universe
first we see the bizarre bug-eyed weasel
resurrected played on set by james's
brother
sean gunn who also provided reference
points for rocket raccoon and the
guardians of the galaxy films the
character first appeared in the pages of
dc comics via 1985's the fury of
firestorm number 36.
believe it or not the john monroe
version of weasel was a stanford
university student and then a teacher at
vandermeer university
much like polkadot man his presence in
comics over the years has generally been
as a punchline both on the page and for
fans in real life
in those early comics he was a serial
killer whose appearance came from a
sharp clawed costume
in the comics he slashed the throat of
the thinker causing rick flagg to kill
him
as far as the movie is concerned weasel
is seen coughing up water and surviving
the carnage on the beach
he scampers away perhaps to head off
into town to grab a drink with lloyd
kaufman and palm clementia in the second
end credits scene we see a pair of
wallers newly emboldened minions rushing
to the hospital
shocked that someone survived the battle
of yotenheim you can be forgiven if you
have your fingers crossed for polka dot
man but alas
lying in that hospital bed is peacemaker
this revelation almost certainly
foreshadows the character's resurrection
in a gun
engineered hbo max peacemaker series one
the filmmaker recently announced he had
completed eight episodes of filming
alongside cena
peacemaker is currently slated to debut
on the streaming service in january 2022
talk about a line that gets maximum
impact with minimum dialogue
when amanda waller introduces robert
dubois by saying
he's in prison for putting superman in
the icu with a kryptonite bullet
you immediately know he's not a man to
be trifled with alas there is no
superman cameo in the suicide squad but
there is a precedent to the whole
kryptonite bullet idea
ask anyone who knows anything about the
man from krypton and they can tell you
the one way to kill superman
kryptonite the fictional material first
appeared in the radio serial the
adventures of superman in june of 1943
followed by its first comic book
appearance in november 1949 superman
number 61.
the material originates from the hero's
home planet is generally harmless to
humans but could potentially prove
lethal for the man of steel
both batman and lex luthor are generally
known to keep some close just in case
the character of bloodsport dates back
to 1987 superman volume 2 number
4 and has since become a longtime
adversary of superman
initially depicted in that post-rambo
time period as a vietnam veteran he was
brought into the fold by luther who
recruited him to assassinate superman
after equipping him with a punisher-like
stash of weapons and included a gun that
fired needles filled with kryptonite
this bloodsport was angry at the
citizens of metropolis
saying they took for granted the
freedoms he and his brother had fought
hard to preserve
after bloodsport slaughtered dozens of
people superman intervened taking a
kryptonite bullet in the process and
requiring medical attention
take a close look at the poster for the
suicide squad and you'll notice several
easter eggs
one is the reigning starfish an obvious
reference to staro
it's the big bad mind controlling
monster task force x battles at the end
of the film
another seems to be referring to the
beloved dc comics miniseries that
introduced the modern suicide squad and
contains some of their earliest
misadventures
first spotted by the site comics beats
the reference can be found masquerading
as a palm tree prawn just under the word
the in the poster tagline they're dying
to save the world
look super close and you'll see it the
word legends
most likely this easter egg refers to
the warmly remembered six issue legends
comic series dc released in 1986 and
1987.
the comics featured new takes on the
flash justice league and captain marvel
but perhaps most significantly
introduced the modern incarnation of the
suicide squad in issue number three
the series had dc heroes battling
darkseid and the third issue had amanda
waller organizing a black ops team to
take on glorious godfrey
one of darkseid's elite and a nuke out
of apocalypse
she selected rick flagg bronze tiger
deadshot enchantress and captain
boomerang for the mission
many of whom are also featured in gunn
and david ayers's films
comics fans love to see a tip of the cap
to those who came before and this minor
acknowledgement of john ostrander len
wing
john byrne carl kessel and others who
helped build the modern suicide squad is
a nice touch
gunn is undoubtedly one of the most
comic book savvy super fans working in
hollywood today and this seems to be an
acknowledgment that the publishing of
legends which would have come out when
he was 20 years old was a formative
experience
his demise might just get the biggest
laugh in the suicide squad an impressive
feat in a movie filled with punch lines
as potent as bloodsport's weaponry
emerging quietly in the background of
the story a seemingly insignificant van
driving character goes from chauffeur to
tag along to full-fledged martyr
inspiring the squad to take down
jotenheim and ultimately rebel against
waller in her program
his name is milton and he first gained
the attention of many sharp-eyed
moviegoers when he could be glimpsed in
the background of the rooftop scene
strutting around like he was another
super powered member of the suicide
squad
when a fan posted a screen grab and
asked who is this dude the twitter savvy
filmmaker simply replied
oh that that's milton comic fans
immediately leapt into action
speculating that he could be the
sideshow character milton fine also
known as the amazing brainiac
or perhaps he's a gender-swapped version
of the female amazon warrior hippolyta
milton if true that could lead to a
connection with wonder woman which could
mean a justice league and suicide squad
crossover
nope it's just milton the stone-faced
ill-fated driver is played by julio ruiz
an actor who has appeared on vice
principles preacher and swat if you want
to see something adorable track down a
march 2021 article from ruiz's hometown
newspaper the laredo morning times
it proudly hypes up the fact that he's
appearing alongside margot robbie idris
elba and other hollywood stars in a
summer tentpole superhero film but
clearly has no idea why
milton's barely acknowledged death
triggers harley quinn as does the
acknowledgement from the others that
they hardly realized he wasn't waiting
in the van
like the death of javelin it emboldens
her to turn tragedy into triumph and
avenge her fallen comrades
are there any grander implications to
the storyline in the dc eu
can we look forward to a batman milton
team-up movie in the near future
probably not but you can follow julio
ruiz on social media for more
information on the mysterious milton
and where his story goes from here check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
suicide squad are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one